from Sports Illustrated the man who
writes those great pieces for mm Q be
calm our friend Albert Brewer back here
on the show how are your Albert I'm good
I'm hanging in there I just kind of got
a little bit pissed by the whole Mike
Gundy thing I'm all did I go in a
goddamn hole yeah
didn't see that coming you know I know
how to set the stage for Pat 40 later on
but you know so what's going on on the
on the front of Colin Kapernick Albert
let's just jump right in on that subject
right off the bat the Commissioner going
on ESPN on that return to sports special
that had so many of the most powerful
people in sports in front of my
Greenberg's QA so the commissioner said
he's encouraging teams to sign him what
what are things staying on that front
right now well I think it's significant
that he said it publicly you know I do
know there were some people you know at
the legal office in 16 and 17 that
really wanted you know Colin
Kaepernick's to find a home and you know
they really felt like it wanted to come
sorry for the league but you know I
think you know sort of the way things
worked back then it yeah I think it was
seen as a way more negative story than
it is now and so you know I think the
fact is the Commissioner feels
comfortable coming out saying it
publicly is significant you know and I
think it also kind of provides cover for
a team to come and sign him because you
know the Commissioner was the first one
to actually speak publicly at length
about it the way that he did so you know
look like I think we've all acknowledged
now like you know big piece of this was
always you know in 16 and 17 up big
piece of the reason why he couldn't find
a home was because a lot of teams
weren't willing to put up with
everything that will come along with
Colin Kaepernick you know what most
would have employed him as a backup
quarterback you know well now if you
look at all that stuff that extra stuff
that comes along with them you know I
think a lot of that stuff was seen as
negative back then
now you know I think for some teams in
some market signing him would be a
positive you know it might be a PR win
for some teams and so that's sort of how
the landscapes changed it doesn't mean
it's not complicated from here but I do
think that you know what the
Commissioner came out you know said was
reflective of a changing attitude across
the league and the fact that he's
willing to say it publicly instead of
just having people in his office talked
about it privately significant too so
here's a question Albert is we just
don't know what Kaepernick thinks of all
this because even if there are a couple
teams that say definitely let's get him
cuz yesterday I made a point and I think
Peter King has made the point I'm sure
you have too that you know in the kovat
1920 20 NFL season and as we've seen
when the NBA multiple positives will not
shut down the sport they're gonna try
and figure this thing out either on the
fly or with as much of a plan in place
in advance the NFL the same way dr.
Allen stills the chief medical officers
on the show I mentioned about having
akikko vat19 protocol similar to the
concussion protocol someone has to clear
it to return he said yes that a
third-string quarterback even could play
a significant role for a team in 2020
NFL season the question is though is
what is Kaepernick 1 what does he want
he hasn't said a word on this front what
do you think he wants Colin you hear
anything on it was I don't know it on
this front you know I wish I had a
better I was at a better answer for yeah
I mean I think really kind of the
operative things here though I know
number one we've seen the NFL
find a way to manufacture jobs for guys
pass right it happened with Michael Sam
you know to a degree with the Cowboys in
2014 and so you know if that's part of
this how does how does Kaepernick look
at that you know what I'm saying like if
you look at that and say well this isn't
on the up-and-up this smells funny I
don't want to do it you know so there's
that element of it like how this whole
thing kind of you know if there is a job
offer how it just sort of manifests
itself so that's one part of it and the
other part of it is you know
somewhere on wall morning with no
guarantee of a job you know I think it's
important to remember that last year in
the league he was in the trade block you
know he was benched in the middle good
in the middle and so you know I think by
definition at the very end you know he
was a USC as a backup quarterback and
now he's been out of the league for
three years and so I mean like look like
he's gonna get into camp and kill it's
possible did he get he finds a home and
it's awesome but it's also possible
three years has taken its toll and so is
he comfortable going somewhere knowing
there's no guarantee that he's gonna
have a job at September just because
he's there in July and on the other side
of that as a team willing to take on the
fact that if you do wind up cutting him
at the end of training camp that could
create a problem for you so you know I
think that those are some of the
complications that they're you know I
think that everybody would have had to
work through you know but I you know I
think the only call I can answer you
know what he actually wants and you know
I think if it's purely I just want a
shot to win a job I just want a shot to
get into a training camp and win a job I
certainly think that that opportunity
will probably be out there for him and
it'll just be I mean I would love to see
it because I would love to say I
remember what he was in 2012-2013 he's
amazing he's doing it even if they're 60
even if there's a piece of that magic
left it will be fun to watch
well I mean in plus you want to talk
about wanting to prove something again
just the question is is the offering of
a job if he feels it's a token gesture
he's not gonna take it and he shouldn't
but there's really no such thing as a
token gesture in 2020 NFL I mean like
again one quarterback context path you
know exactly I mean this is a
significant necessity to get as many
quarterbacks that can play the game on
your team don't you think I mean in this
year right sure no question and here you
know it's interesting you know I think
with the Bruce Arians there was someone
else that said publicly talked about a
quarantine at quarterback right there
were two coaches
week two talked about that I you know
I've heard multiple teams talk about the
idea of having meetings with their
quarterbacks in separate rooms because
they don't we could be used to be risky
to have them together all the time if
say one of the guys gets it even if he's
asymptomatic you know you increase the
likelihood that you wipe out your entire
quarterback room you wipe out your
quarterback firm you're screwed you know
and so I certainly think there exists
this possibility where if I'm one of
these teams
maybe I'm bringing like five
quarterbacks to camp rich because I just
want to have five quarterbacks that know
my system you bet knowing I might cut
two of them but those two guys are out
there on the street I know I've got
those guys sort of in reserve if there's
some sort of outbreak you know my team
so I'm with you I think that there's
going to be those sorts of opportunities
out there for guys you know and again I
I think that the question then becomes
under what context does Colin want to
return to the league and that's a
question that's I think you know only he
can answer it well Anthony Lynn has just
been quoted as saying Kaepernick fits
the style of quarterback the Chargers
want and they have own a potential
quote-unquote workout list and again
Turab Taylor is your current starting
quarterback right there and so it sure
looks like and again Los Angeles would
be a city I think that would absolutely
have no issue with Colin Kaepernick
getting a gig here and I'm sure there
were others who would disagree with this
but the bottom line is the guy is good
enough and has played in a Super Bowl
and this year we have more opportunities
for any quarterback than I can remember
to play a significant role an important
role that would be and of course
Anthony Lin being a person of color at
the head coaching spot to say that he
wants to do it and that he would be the
guy to do it
let's roll right I mean that would be
yeah yeah I would love the idea of it
here's the problem I wrote the problem
with that rich is like what this chance
is making the team
if you assume like Tyrod Taylor is on
the roster right because you started
right now
Justin Herbert isn't going anywhere
correct you know as your second string
guy or potentially your starter because
you Dracula and fit though for all but
he's going to be a senior and then you
know Easton stick in the dog I know a
lot a lot of hurdles but they spent a
year in developing so you know I think
that that's going to be sort of yeah you
know I think for any fire you know and
in this sort of position it's you know
where do I have the best chance of
making the team and I'm with you on
everything you said you know about about
what's the potential opportunity with
the Chargers there but is that the best
situation for cap you know and I think
that like if you look at it across the
NFL there might be better chances for
him to make a team get on the field
somewhere I'm rather than the Chargers
I'm with you as far as just the
logistics the way that sets up that it
would make sense for a few different
rate Albert Brewer here in the Rich
Eisen show and then oh by the way there
is a former MVP still out there who is
in Los Angeles we saw him working out
with Odell Beckham what is the scoop
with Cam Newton as we're talking about
so many different opportunities for
quarterbacks but I assume he's waiting
for the what Teddy Bridgewater type
injury that would have hurt hurt happen
and he would then swoop in in is that is
that his plan right now to get a game in
2020 yeah people around him and I'm
sorry I'm outside and cars around so
it's all good it's all guy you're about
the hustle and bustle anyway yeah I so I
so you know what's with Canada I have
heard that he's so people around him
he's not really interested right now and
going to a place where he would be sort
of the firm number two or a mentor to a
young quarterback like that's not the
sort of job that he's looking for and so
you know would he go somewheres a backup
maybe but I don't think he's gonna do a
little backup where he's firmly the
number two and the only chance you're
gonna play there's something
catastrophic gap with the starter and so
you know I think that's why he's content
to sit sort of wait this thing out a
little bit and you know then
yeah but one or two things has to happen
either you've got a team like a New
England a Denver a Jacksonville where
they got a young quarterback in place
and maybe things don't free out the way
they thought it was they would what's
the young quarterback does they haven't
had them in the spring and everything
else or someone gets shows like you said
like a Ryan Tannehill situation a few
years ago when Jay Cutler came in like
the Bridgewater situation oh yeah it
seems like for right now Cam's content
too late for something like that to pop
up in the summer it's risky of course
you know but I think he not only wants
to be on a team in 2020 he wants the
client 2020 albert pre here on the Rich
Eisen show and what what are you hearing
about the 20/20 stuff you heard on our
buddy lock and fours local show in
Baltimore John Harbaugh say some of the
health and safety protocols just merely
for training camp were impossible
impossible nothing's gonna be perfect
here certainly in a sport where a huddle
or merely getting a set over a football
there's no social distancing whatsoever
so what are you hearing about this
Albert I you know I've heard like sort
of a preliminary list of protocols I'm
just gonna allow the teams to prepare
for training camp you know when to some
degree I think it was a press release
too you know and like letting the public
know and letting the players know
letting everyone know when we do get to
training camp I there are things that
would be logistically very difficult the
limits on obviously the limits on you
know what you can do in a locker room
you know I talked to one head coach who
you know said like we're gonna need
three locker rooms based on our own
logistics to make it work so you know I
I think for for each of these teams
there's you know challenges that is very
very difficult to deal with based on the
way the sport is and based on the way
these facilities are set up
everything else that said you know while
every coach I talked to over the last
week agreed with fireball ie there's
also this feeling that a month from now
we're going to have more information
than we do right now and so there's
certainly the possibility that some of
these things are tweaked or adjusted
based on what we see and say the Premier
League or what we see and say the
Bundesliga in Germany or maybe some of
the information they're able to gather
when NBA teams and NHL teams get that
practicing I guess it's not like oh for
baseball but no I think there's that
turn that feel I think there is that
feeling that they're going to have more
information about a month from now so
what's the big story outside of anything
that I've just asked you because I mean
the DAC signing for for the Cowboys
that's July 15th I mean that's yep
that's like a million light years away
based on everything else that we're
talking about right now is there
anything else that I'm missing them
we're not we're not hitting on because
the collective bargaining agreement
thank goodness you seen what's going on
with baseball could you imagine if that
thing had not passed shortly before the
pandemic hit yeah and what the
conversations would be on both sides to
try and get everybody in or are there
gonna be conversations like that you're
already seeing the NBA and the NBA PA
you know they are lockstep but there was
a little bit of a hiccup you've seen
what's going on with baseball is there
any issue do you think that we're gonna
encounter on that front with the NFL
here a couple weeks ago actively you
know civil they're coming the players in
the league and the responsive guys yeah
that's cologne yet oh I think that that
eventually is going to have to come but
it's different than in other sports so
on other sports they're talking about
current year money right like baseball
basketball hockey you know some of those
discussions are about current year money
for the NFL it's really going to affect
the 2021 cap more and so the
negotiations that are going to have to
take place are how do we make sure
there's not a fall on the cap in
21 which is probably going to mean
borrowing money from future years and so
that's going to mean the cap could be
affected two and three years out based
on where how much revenue they lose in
2020 so those are the sorts of things
they have to discuss I don't think
that's going to get away of camp of the
season starting on time but there are
hard discussions that they're going to
need to have you know another max I
either you know some intriguing story
mentions dak Prescott Jadeveon Clowney
is another one he's still out there
former number one overall pick you know
and then I sense the mess that the set
up camps going to be where I think
you're gonna see a lot more roster
churning than you normally see just
because a lot of these teams haven't
seen their refuge physically yet they
haven't seen some of the free agent
space all right and so I think we could
see a lot of roster churning it started
training camp which is going to make for
a very very busy July and August for a
lot of tianjin and then I would say I
mean the one thing everybody needs to be
ready for is how the cold is 19
you know protocols are going to reach
into reserve way and you know how it's
going to allow for teams to have almost
taxi squads of players available or you
know how they're going to be able to
manage it if there's an outbreak on the
roster because everybody knows I mean
you have 53 guys on a roster when the
season starts I mean if this thing hits
12 this thing you know
yeah twelve guys test positive even if
they're asymptomatic you're probably
gonna have to tell them and that's a
devastating loss for a team so how do
you manage that so that's some of those
stuff they're gonna have they still have
to work through they haven't worked
through yet as far as the you know
specific coronavirus protocols and I've
got Thomas Moore stat on at the top of
our final hour the punter from the
Saints what are you hearing about the
the I guess
aftermath of Brees his comments to Yahoo
Finance and then his apology publicly on
various social medias and then to his
teammates what are you hearing about the
aftermath there if there is one point
yeah you know I talked to tomorrow
that's about this last week and uh you
know I think it's like for him it was
you know he's taking braces or but he
wants to see freezin Paul I think that's
sort of where the conversation you know
has changed and we're you know players
are right now is yeah I think standing
on the sidelines isn't okay anymore and
whatever sort of protests we see when we
get in September that players are really
looking for full participation from
other guys who may not have been
inclined to participate in the past and
so I think that's part of the fallout
for breeze
I mean look you've got IO 19 years of
capital built up as an NFL player
capital built up in the Saints locker
room they know who he is
you know but I think now you know the
next step becomes sort of vertical for
drew in showing in showing the players
that showing the other players in that
locker room he's behind them because the
one takeaway the guys like Malcolm
Jenkins at the Mario pad so they want to
please video was yeah he hasn't listened
to us so now I think it's on breathe to
show no I have been listening to you I
do care about what you guys are talking
about and here's how I'm going to show
you Albert you're the breast really
appreciate this normally I would say
this stuff off the air but I just want
to bring it on the air since you know I
don't know the next time we're gonna
talk but the next time you're on this
show I am gonna require you to sign a
waiver but I'm gonna call it a pledge
the Rich Eisen show pledge you're gonna
have to sign the pledge if you can have
your family members sign it as well that
would be that would be also required but
again it's we don't view it as a legal
document here it's just a pledge to the
Rich Eisen show oh okay
I just want to let you know because it
might not be that different than what
comes not from South might it might
I'm here in 46 how about that are you
saying that that liability may be a
concern on every college campus football
program become public over time and yeah
are you saying you're not signing the
Rich Eisen show pledge that's not really
a waiver I'd say you know what you know
I'll get back to you you know what
just wanted to just let you know our
guests okay all of our guests just to
make sure that we're all in the clear
probably at 17 to1 chance that I find
that okay take care of it you take care
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here